airport there's a group of women and
children
they left their home in north east kiev
two days ago when it became too
dangerous to stay
i
started to hear
bombs
in our cities
and
russia comes to our city
[Music]
on the ukrainian polish border
exhausted women and children keep coming
poland is offering some kind of safety
from the hell that they've left behind
very difficult two and three days
we have we have awful awful terrible
terrible days
so so you're relieved
[Music]
the quickest way out of here is by bus
but by now everyone is cold and
desperate
they're bewildered and who can blame
them
not everyone can get on the bus is full
and so they wait patiently
everyone is here because they fear being
bombed and killed in their own country
they fear their neighbor who is killing
and continuing to kill the numbers are
just extraordinary now
around a million people have crossed
through polish borders alone
the amount of people who've left ukraine
is thought to be near a 2 million and
that number could double in the next few
weeks alone
and everywhere you look from every angle
there are women and children
with suitcases their whole lives packed
up
and they're now on the move
this little boy just a toddler takes
charge of the bag to help his mum babies
cry
and mothers muster all that they have
to press on
to keep safe
nick martin sky news on the ukrainian
polish border